yeah but what typically happens is most
of them become leftover right most of
them just go on the [ __ ] Carousel and
have their fun and then they use
relationships as a break from the [ __ ]
Carousel and they'll fall in love and
they'll post that person on Facebook and
Instagram you know but like I finally
found a step daddy for my son and
daughter and then they'll break up
they'll delete all the pictures that
[ __ ] is a vicious cycle right then by
the time they hit 40 and 44 they like uh
I'm living my best life and they'll be
they'll have money they'll have a good
job and they'll have a Mercedes C-Class
Mercedes and they'll they'll be balling
out of control they'll ball out until
they fall out then 50 hits
and they are done
done it's it's a disaster by then it's a
disaster what they're going to hope now
is that some dudes gonna take that deal
if they ride it out to that most guys
and this sometimes happen mid-40s it
just depends most guys don't take that
deal